Pride Month is upon us in corporate
America is cashing in on America's
obsession with unusual sex we will
analyze how the queen of sin became our
culture's favorite virtue then the
mainstream media misrepresent a
surprising poll on abortion and 2020
Democrats continue to humiliate
themselves I'm Michael Knowles and this
is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's Pride Month in honor of that I'm
wearing a lavender shirt this was just a
happy coincidence actually and the pride
is the issue by the way we'll be talking
about pride because pride is called
the queen of all sin the queen of all
vices and as drew was saying on his show
today pride has now also become the vice
of all queens so so he'll be analyzing
the relationship between pride and all
of these sex parades but first let me
tell you about big token let me make you
a little bit of money big token is a new
app that lets you share data about
yourself your interests and your habits
and then get paid for it right now you
share an enormous amount of information
with tech companies you are sharing it
right now on whatever app and whatever
instrument you're using the big tech
companies make a lot of money off of it
and so should you this is where big
token comes in here's how it works first
you download the app and you sign up for
a free big token account then you
complete actions to earn points and this
can include answering surveys checking
into locations checking connecting to
your social accounts and more so how
much time do you weigh it's just swiping
mindlessly you can actually be making
money while you do it because you can
redeem your points for rewards such as
cash and gift cards or if you're a nice
guy you can donate your earnings to
charity you can choose what data you
share with big token then you get paid
for the data and you can also get more
points for referring family and friends
most importantly your data are always
secured with big token based on the data
you choose to share you will be placed
into specific ad groups brands will buy
access to those ad groups it's very
transparent and it's used in
personalized advertising the best part
of it though is you get paid don't just
scroll mindlessly don't fritter away
your time if you want to start earning
money for your data go to the App Store
or Google Play
search for big token b.i.g Tok en that
is one word download the app and sign up
and this is a great way to earn some
money or donate to charity in your spare
time with data that you're already
giving away for free make sure to use my
referral code Knolls KO wles again
search big token in the App Store or
Google Play
download the app and use my referral
code this is the
most important part because then I get
credit ko wles to sign up claim your
data and get paid happy pride everybody
happy Pride Month not gluttony month not
wrath month not sloth month Pride Month
Pride Month is upon us the Pride Month
used to be the Pride Parade so there was
one day and I'm from New York so they
have all these kind of crazy pride
events in New York and have had them for
20 years now Pride Day has become a
whole month which means that everyone is
cashing in on the popularity of unusual
sex primarily and then pride now it
probably even more than that this
includes corporations politicians even
priests are cashing in on the popularity
of pride on the corporate front nowhere
is this more apparent than Budweiser
Budweiser beer the most basic beer in
the whole world
everyone likes Budweiser Budweiser is
now supporting Pride Month in London
they sent a tweet announcing their
support for Pride and then as a follow
up to this they have unveiled their new
beer drinking cups for every kind of
sexual preference we're not just talking
about gay and lesbian we are talking
about sexual preferences that you didn't
even know were sexual preferences their
first cup that they unveiled they said
fly the flag for by pride by pride I
they they say magenta
they haven't divided up into a few
different colors magenta is for same
gender attraction Blue is for attraction
to genders other than your own and
lavender a mix of the two represents
attraction to your own and other genders
there's some interpret it differently
okay all right I mean the first thing is
they talk about all of these different
genders so it's it's not just that
you're attracted to the other gender or
it's for your own gender they're all of
these genders according to Facebook
there are 56 of them your beer cup now
has to reflect that apparently you
thought you could just drink beer no no
you have to reflect you're very precise
always changing sexual preferences and
let's say though that you don't
like sex very much Budweiser is
inclusive even of that because they have
a cup for asexuals who quote don't feel
sexual attraction to anyone gray is for
grey asexuals who sometimes feel sexual
attraction and demisexuals who only feel
it if they know someone well white nods
to non-asexual allies and purple
represents the whole community but if
the whole community is people who like
sex and who don't like sex and who
sometimes like sex and who always liked
sex then that's all the people so that's
probably the safest cup that you can buy
because you know if your wife for
instance says that she has a headache
one night when you come home she I guess
for that evening would be asexual or
maybe she just doesn't like you so she
would be demisexual she wants to have
sex just not with you then she'll have
that cup and you who really really want
to have sex all the time can also drink
out of that cup which is gray white and
black for Pride Month because you like
sex and it's inclusive of the whole
community just a reminder we're talking
about beer every everybody drinks beer
everyone likes beer beer by the way is
the best cure that I've ever seen for
asexuality so and demisexuality the more
beer you drink it turns out you our
threshold for sex increases your
standards kind of dropped down as well
maybe they'll put that in the follow up
to the campaign but it's beer everybody
likes beer Brett Kavanaugh likes beer he
still likes beer I still like beer
everyone likes it you can drink it out
of any cup but Budweiser needs to cash
in on Pride Month because pride is the
virtue of our culture we all love pride
and it's not just Budweiser all of
Corporate America does this the reason
that they do this is because right now
they see marketing to people with
curious sexualities as all upside and no
downside 50 years ago if you tried to
market to gay people you would you would
have your corporation boycott back when
America was more sexually repressed
before the sexual revolution you
couldn't do that now there's actually a
lot of downside if you don't advertise
toward curious sexualities
I say curious sexualities instead of gay
or lesbian because pride has now
expanded to include every sexuality as
Budweiser shows it even includes non
sexuality and this is smart marketing
because everybody has some sort of weird
sexual preference it's not just gay guys
every single person in America like some
kind of weird aspect of sex and I'm sure
Budweiser has a cup for you as well and
and in in Budweiser's defense at least
they're just talking about the sex part
so they say they're embracing Pride
Month but they really just focus it on
sex and as we know from marketing 101
sex sells and so I I can kind of go with
it other organizations other politicians
even other priests are not just focusing
on the sex part they are taking it up a
notch and talking about pride itself
this includes 2020 Democrat presidential
candidates including liya Wafaa Liz
Warren who did not just affirm her
support of boys who like boys and girls
who like girls she came out for pride
dancing in the street in the Boston
Pride Parade wearing a rainbow feather
boa here she is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I love marching and Boston pride because
a homage is about love
we need more than
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the first bride that I'm engaged I'm
celebrating
so she's out there she's the Grand
Poobah Elizabeth Warren of the Boston
Pride Parade and she tweeted out and
said quote Pride Month is a celebration
and it's a time to remember the
trailblazers who fought for lgbtq+ civil
rights every year you add another letter
today and every day we renew our
commitment to fight until everyone can
live proudly without fear I'll be right
there alongside you happy pride
so you notice there's not really much
mention of sex anywhere which is
ostensibly the purpose of Pride Parade
but in that tweet there are three
mentions of pride so we're figuring out
this is about something a little bit
more than sex and it's not just Liz
Warren even a Catholic priest got in on
the celebration of pride before we get
to that let's talk about something
that's a lot more serious which is
finding a new job finding a new job is a
lot of work and this if as I talked to
my millennial friends they're always
looking for a new job what if you had
your own personal recruiter to help you
find a better job
now zip recruiters technology can do
that for you we love zip recruiter we we
love to use them here at The Daily wire
to hire people but I've long wondered if
people trying to get a job could use it
just as well and now zip recruiter can
do that for you you just download the
zip recruiter job search app you let it
know what kinds of jobs you're
interested in and it's technology starts
doing the work the zip recruiter app
finds jobs that you will like and puts
your profile in front of employers who
may be looking for someone like you if
an employer likes your profile zip
recruiter lets you know so that if
you're interested in the job you can
apply no wonder zip recruiter is the
number one rated job search app if I had
known about this when I was looking for
a job there was a chance that I wouldn't
just be the pizza boy for The Daily wire
there's a chance that I wouldn't be
operating out of a broom closet 18 hours
a day my listeners right now should
download the app free app zip recruiter
job search app today let the power of
technology work for you don't wait the
sooner you download the free zip
recruiter job search app the sooner it
can help you find a better job there is
no better way to get a better job do it
right now you will not regret it so it's
not just the
corporations and the politicians getting
in on the celebration of pride even a
Catholic priest is doing it there's a
guy named father James Martin who
tweeted out he said to all my many LGBTQ
friends Catholic and otherwise happy
Pride Month be proud of your god-given
dignity of the gifts God has given to
you of your place in the world and of
your many contributions to the church
for you are quote wonderfully made by
God
hashtag Pride Month 2019 so he talks
about pride mostly a little bit on
sexual preference this is a little
strange for father Martin because the
Catholic Church teaches that homosexual
acts are intrinsically disordered so in
his job and his role as a priest it's a
strange thing for him to say but let's
put that aside for a second I think so
many discussions of Pride Month are are
ruined because people want to focus on
the sex aspect sex has become a very
minor aspect of Pride Month there's no
real reason why pride and sex need to be
connected put the sex aside why pride
why pride according to Thomas Aquinas
pride is the queen of all sin it's not
just a regular sin it is the worst sin
it is the the beginning of all sin in
the Bible at which father Martin might
consider reading at some point it says
pride goes before destruction and a
haughty spirit before a fall in the book
of ecclesiasticus it says the beginning
of man's pride is to depart from the
Lord his heart has forsaken his maker
for the beginning of pride is sin then
you have a priest saying quote the
direct quote happy Pride Month be proud
that doesn't make a whole lot of sense
does it
politicians doing the same thing and
corporations doing the same thing
why is pride the worst of all sins it's
because it caused man to fall the sin in
the Garden of Eden is the sin of pride
the sin that caused Satan to fall from
heaven is the sin of pride pride
convinces you that you are better than
you are it it convinces you to be
disrespectful toward other
derisively missive of other people
if this Pride Month were really just
about sex and specifically gay sex it
wouldn't be called Pride Month it would
be what like if gay people really just
wanted to be sort of tolerated by
society and accepted by society why
would they choose for their motto the
worst sin of all why wouldn't they at
least choose some lesser sin like wrath
or gluttony or sloth
why wouldn't they call it if they really
were serious about just being accepted
by society why not call it sexual
tolerance month sexual open-mindedness
month why is it called pride it's
because the left has a far bigger agenda
than sexual tolerance sex is just the
way in because we all love sex and we
think about sex all the time and it's a
good way to kind of pull people in and
attract people so at this point
homosexuality I think is totally
tangential to Pride Month now it's about
gender it's about sexual identity so now
there aren't just two genders there are
56 different genders and there is a
sexual pride there is fat pride there's
skinny pride there's all kinds of pride
what is pride pride is excessive love of
one's own excellence it pride is it's
the opposite of humility
if pride is the queen of all sin
humility is the queen of the virtues and
they're exactly opposite vice and virtue
sin and virtue are the opposite and
pride and humility are exact opposites
we know that humility is the beginning
of all wisdom we know this from
Scripture we know this just from our own
experience proud people come off like
idiots when you'd meet a proud person no
matter how popular they are no matter
how many credentials they have they seem
like idiots and when you meet a humble
person even if he has no education if he
even if he's from a humble station in
life they often come off as very wise so
in a healthy culture we approach serious
questions with humility serious people
approach questions with humility so
instead of pride parades if we had a
humble culture
and people who have differing sexual
preferences wanted to be more accepted
they might have a parade that was called
be please don't ostracize me for my
sexual preferences parade or my sexual
behavior parade humility would be the
recognition that we are all very flawed
people which is certainly the case every
single person that you have ever met is
a very flawed person pride is the
opposite pride is the fantasy that we're
all perfect and that is what is being
embraced by the left that is the agenda
being pushed by the left the leftist
agenda is to suggest that human nature
is perfectible we're on our way to
progress that's what progress with a
capital P means and so progressives see
the Utopia they see perfect human nature
and we're just marching there
we're so close just give us a little bit
more money in a little bit more power
and we have a culture that values the
self above all other things so in a good
culture you have selflessness you have
people doing acts of charity for each
other
you have people sacrificing for for each
other for their children for future
generations but in our culture we don't
have selflessness we don't have people
we're about to have the 75th anniversary
of the d-day invasion of storming
Normandy that was an act of selflessness
for the country that's unimaginable
today today what we have are parades
celebrating the self we have self love
we have self care we have selfishness
selfishness is replaced by selfishness
and humility is replaced by pride it is
a horrible thing no matter your sexual
preferences no matter your sexual views
no matter your religious views no matter
your moral views pride is terrible it
will ruin society and it will ruin your
life if you live in a proud way if you
think you're so great and everyone else
is just kind of shorting you and
cheating you and you got a big chip on
your shoulder and everyone's worse than
you are and you're so much better than
everyone else you're going to have a
terrible life do not be proud you have
no reason to be proud you should be
humble we should have humility parades
that's a good example I mean every
single person has some sort of weird
sexual desires statistically every
person who has ever walked the earth has
some sort of weird sexual desire which
is why these sorts of parades are
compelling to people because they say oh
well I've got kind of weird sexual
desires there but for the grace of God
go I that is a cause for humility it's a
cause for saying mmm gosh I'm I'm a
little bit off we're all a little bit
off okay maybe we should be aware of
that it is not a source of pride we
should not have pret not in our sex not
in our physical appearances not in error
we shouldn't have pride in any of those
things even in our intelligence we
shouldn't take pride even in you know we
talk about national pride how much we're
proud we are of our country even
national pride I wouldn't use that term
I have a devotion to my country I have a
love for my country I have a loyalty to
my country in my countrymen but I don't
know that it's pride per se it's it's
more personal it's more real it's more
tangible it's more of a relationship
that would be a healthy culture but we
don't live in a healthy culture so get
ready for more feather boas on Elizabeth
Warren thankfully she didn't wear a a
rainbow headdress I think that might
have even that would have brought her
poll numbers down from single digits
down to zero maybe down to negative so
Ellie she's just got the rainbow feather
boa she's not the only 2020 presidential
candidate though who's making a complete
fool of herself there are several others
probably you haven't even heard of them
one guy is a congressman from
Massachusetts an Iraq war veteran Seth
Moulton he was doing a town hall on CNN
and Seth Moulton decided he's going to
pitch his presidential campaign make his
pitch to the country on the slogan that
America is racist areas
we have a problem with racism in America
today if this country wasn't racist
Stacey Abrams would be governor this guy
is so stupid Stacey Abrams you might not
remember her she's the lady who ran for
governor of Georgia and lost and
wouldn't concede refuses to admit that
she lost so she's still pretending that
she won and so Seth Moulton is saying if
this country weren't racist Stacey
Abrams would be governor that's historic
I guess if you you would extrapolate his
argument his argument would be if this
country weren't racist forget just
Stacey Abrams if this country weren't
racist black people would be elected to
office so you might say if this country
weren't racist a candidate like Barack
Obama would be elected to oh hold on
wait a minute never mind we've elected a
black president so that part of the
argument kind of falls apart actually if
Seth Moulton knew a thing about history
which I suspect he doesn't black people
have served in high elected office not
just for the past ten years since Barack
Obama they've served in high elected
office for the last hundred and fifty
years century and a half the first black
person elected to high office elected to
the US Senate was the Republican Hiram
Rhodes revels in 1870 149 years ago did
I mention he was a Republican I just
wanted to get that out there he was then
followed by the Republican Blanche Bruce
elected to the US Senate in 1875 second
black US Senator but there were other
people in the meantime in 1870 after the
Civil War
Joseph Rainey a black Republican was
elected to Congress he was the first
black member of Congress to be popularly
elected and seated and immediately
thereafter black people were elected to
national office all over the place
Alabama Florida Georgia Louisiana
Mississippi North Carolina Texas and
Virginia all over the place this
happened 150 years ago then after that
Democrats disenfranchised black people
for a few decades
so they brought in Jim Crow they brought
in illegal election laws and so they
were run out of office and their right
to vote was compromised then however in
the modern era which begins call it 1928
would be the first black elected
official to high national office in the
modern era that was the black Republican
Oscar de priest who became a member of
Congress in total there have been 10
black senators in the history of the
United States there have been 153 black
congressmen and there's been a black
president every time a black person
loses a race is not an example of racism
Stacey Abrams lost the race they won't
get over this Hillary Clinton lost the
race Al Gore lost the race I'm sorry
every - it's amazing
that during 2016 all we heard was this
threat that if Donald Trump loses the
election he he won't admit it he won't
concede the election Hillary Clinton
said that if Donald Trump didn't concede
the election it would destroy our
democracy and then what happens
Democrats lose the elections and they
never concede I think Al Gore still
thinks that he's the President of the
United States Hillary Clinton still
think she's the rightful president she
talks about it the Russians stole it the
macedonians stolen the James Comey
stolen Stacey Abrams lost she didn't
lose by five votes she lost fifty point
two percent to forty eight point eight
percent that's a close election but it's
decisive wasn't five votes it wasn't 10
votes it was fifty five thousand votes
and this is a bizarre way I mean Seth
Moulton is going nowhere he'll probably
be out before the first debate he's not
even registering in the polls but if
Seth Moulton wants to launch himself as
a serious candidate he's got military
service he's a current congressman so he
has some chance to do it why would you
launch the campaign trying to relitigate
a failed governor's bid in Georgia
she lost the people of Georgia had their
say no one cares beta or orc should be
the lesson for everybody
even the Democrats
ultimately don't like a loser so it's
true CNN will have Stacey Abrams on she
can say I really won the election
secretly I'm the real secret governor of
Georgia CNN can have Hillary Clinton on
she'll say I really won the election I'm
secretly the real President of the
United States but they're not
we hate losers in America even the
Democrats are not immune to this why on
earth would you keep just relitigated
this rehashing this it's just evidence
that he's going nowhere but there was an
even bigger problem that the Democrats
have in 2020 and John Hickenlooper who I
guess is running he's the former
Colorado governor he ran into this issue
at a major Democratic in California he
found out the one thing that you can't
say if you want to get past the Democrat
primary in 2020 we will get to that then
we will get to a surprising new poll on
Roe vs. Wade that the mainstream media
are screaming about and if we have time
we'll get to aoc but first I've got to
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
go to daily wire.com ten bucks a month
$100 for an annual membership you and me
you get the Andrew Klavan show you get
the Ben Shapiro show you get them out
wall show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag you get another Kingdom you
get to ask questions backstage you get
the leftist here's tumblr mm-hmm that's
some of that good old Georgia moonshine
that's some of that good old Stacey
Abrams lost the race maroon it still
tastes good it's a little aged now so
it's got it's got a little age on it
make sure that you get yours because
2020 could flood your house you and your
family make sure you get at least one
left us tears tumblr to survive we will
be right back stick around
so Seth Moulton is not the only wacko
2020 candidate the there is another one
John Hickenlooper who is he's so wacky
because he's so sane he is the former
governor of Colorado and he said an
event for California Democrats and he's
trying to pull his party back from the
brink so he says listen guys I really
want us to win in 2020 I really hate
Donald Trump I really want to Institute
democrat policies we're not going to be
able to do that if we keep pushing
socialism on the American people here is
the reaction that he got if we want to
beat Donald Trump and achieve big
progressive goals socialism is not the
answer I was reelected
I was reelected in a purple state in
2014 one of the worst years for
Democrats in a quarter century I was we
shouldn't try to achieve universal
coverage by removing private insurance
from over a hundred and fifty million
Americans we should not try to tackle
climate change by guaranteeing every
American a government job hold on hold
on as a Democratic Party we have to
create a vision for this country I want
to give Americans a reason to look
forward to tomorrow they're screwed the
Democrats are completely screwed if
that's the reaction that he's getting by
saying hey we're not socialists we
shouldn't just have a totally socialist
government that gives a job to everybody
like we're Maoist China or something if
the reaction is boo boo boo if he has to
say wait wait hold on let me finish that
party is in deep deep trouble how can
they possibly win it's not like this guy
is some conservative is the former
governor of Colorado he's in an event
for California Democrats and he is just
acknowledging a flat electoral reality
which is that the American majority of
Americans will not vote for a socialist
this is a fact few Democrat politicians
watch this show so I'm not worried that
they'll get the secret out here but the
most most Americans will not vote for a
socialist according to a 2018 poll from
hill TV and harris x american barometer
seventy six percent of americans would
not vote for a socialist that is
overwhelming that is decisive
a more recent poll just came out just
last month from Monmouth University 57%
of Americans believe that socialism is
incompatible with American values we
should have known that I mean President
Trump reads the polls president Trump is
pretty good at putting his finger on the
pulse of the American people he came out
during that State of the Union and said
America will never be a socialist
country it's one of the greatest lines
of any speech he's given
his entire presidency and yet most
Democratic candidates for president are
running as socialists make no mistake
they don't all use the word socialist
some of them do obviously Bernie Sanders
does and has for decades but they are
all running as socialists virtually all
of them have embraced the green New Deal
the green New Deal is socialism it is a
radical form of socialism it's a 93
trillion dollar socialist plan that
would give the government control over
virtually the entire economy it would
give the government control over 90% of
the American energy industry over the
entire healthcare industry which is
one-sixth of the economy overall
transportation planes trains and
automobiles it would give them control
over agriculture by killing off all the
poor cows it would give them control
over housing over every single building
in this country the government would be
allowed to knock it down and build it
back up actually it goes even further
the green New Deal would give a
committee just some random committees
set up by the green New Deal the right
to establish virtually any other policy
that the committee sees fit it would be
a fundamental reordering of our
political structure the Congress would
give over its ability to legislate to
some random committee of experts and and
progressives that who they know they're
the right people to run our lives for us
this is a big deal and it's not that
Biden is the moderate it's not that
Camela is the moderate no they're
virtually all embracing this and it's
very unpopular so you guys like
Hickenlooper saying please please don't
do this to us please let us win this
election and they're getting booed even
if this guy could make the case let me
get through the primary and I'll win the
general how is he going to get through
that primary if the majority of
Democrats are booing him here now that's
just socialism which is which is
obviously a major issue and it probably
will give Donald Trump the 2020 election
there's another fundamental issue on
which the Democrats are way off from the
American people you might not know it
from the mainstream media but that issue
is abortion and here's what I mean about
the mainstream media there is a headline
today in the hill and the headline says
poll nearly half of Americans say
Supreme Court should uphold Roe vs. Wade
so you read that headline you just
glanced at it you see it on Twitter and
you say okay well I guess we should
uphold Roe vs. Wade because that's what
the wording says right it says Supreme
Court should uphold Roe vs. Wade they
say wait a second does that that says
half of Americans oh so the other half
maybe think we shouldn't uphold Roe vs.
Wade then you see the word nearly so to
translate that you could say poll less
than half Americans say the Supreme
Court should uphold Roe vs. Wade you
could actually make it even more honest
and say poll the majority of Americans
want to significantly change or overturn
Roe vs. Wade the majority this is what
the article says quote 46 percent of
respondents said the High Court should
uphold the ruling in Roe if the issue
comes before the justices well 36
percent said the Supreme Court should
modify the 46 year old ruling 18% wanted
the ruling to be overturned altogether
so you've got a group of Americans 18
percent nearly one in five say that Roe
versus Wade should be completely
overturned then you have a group that's
about that's exactly twice as big as
that 36 percent which says that the
Supreme Court should modify the decision
which is to say it should overturn it
right I mean it should it should modify
key aspects of it how do you modify a
constitutional right to abortion you say
that there isn't an absolute
constitutional right to abortion and
then you have the minority of people 46
percent who say we should uphold Roe vs.
Wade this is a major win for pro-life
this is a major win for conservatives
and the Democrat Party is so radical on
this issue they're the mainstream media
are trying to present all these states
that want to limit abortion as being the
radical ones virtually every
presidential candidate running on the
Democrat side supports abortion up until
the point of birth even the so-called
moderates even the so-called reasonable
ones here is Kirsten Gillibrand she's on
Fox News talking about the question of
abortion and she's asked
very point-blank what do you think about
late term abortion she can't answer it
what I'm asking you senator is what is
your position on late term abortion or
last trimester abortions well thank you
for serving our community and helping
our babies particular our preemies who
deeply need the medical care they have
my view on women's reproductive freedom
is that it should be a woman's decision
to make these most intimate
life-and-death decisions for themselves
okay just to cut her off right here
abortion is not a life-and-death
decision for the mother abortion is a
life-and-death decision for the baby
there is virtually no case in which
abortion is required to save a mother's
life you you could treat the mother if
she has some condition and that
treatment might consequentially end the
life of the baby but there is no case in
which the cure for some ailment of the
mother is abortion it is not a life and
death decision for the mother at all it
is a decision of a little bit of
discomfort I guess if you carry a baby
to term but it is not life and death
it's only life and death for the baby
then she realizes that's a bad answer
so she says gosh the only way that I'm
gonna be able to get out of this is if I
just randomly start attacking Fox News
we have created unfortunately it's a
false choice and a false narrative and
Chris I want to talk about the role that
Fox News plays in this because it's a
problem I can tell you before President
Trump gave his State of the Union Fox
News talked about infanticide there's an
aside it doesn't exist senator I just
want to say we brought you here for an
hour we have given you we're treating
you very fairly I understand that maybe
to make your credentials with the with
the Democrats who are not appearing on
Fox News you you're going to attack us
I'm not sure it's frankly very polite
when okay we've invited you here I will
do in a plate way but it's well I just I
just
why don't we instead of talking about
Fox News why don't you answer simple
question Oh Greg gotta love Chris
Wallace sometimes sometimes he's kind of
a rude interviewer because he interrupts
people but in this case it worked out
really well because she says no I have
to attack Fox News because I have
nothing to say on abortion and he says
well how about instead of talking about
Fox how about you just
answer the question so she gets called
out on it then she tries to answer the
question and the only way that she can
try to answer the question is to lie
about what's actually happening the
debate about whether or not women should
have reproductive freedom has turned
into a red herring debate and what
happens on fox news is relevant because
they talked about infanticide for 6.5
hours 6.5 hours right before president
Trump's State of the Union mentioned it
35 times that is not the debate of what
access to reproductive care is in this
country it doesn't happen it's illegal
it's not a fact so none of what she said
is true
other than that Fox News talked about it
35 times okay I'll talk about it at 36th
time Democrats are endorsing undeniable
infanticide don't take my word for it
definitely don't take Kirsten Gillibrand
word for it cuz she's a liar here is the
Democrat elected governor of Virginia
our old pal the guy who when you can't
see him it's probably because he's
wearing a KKK mask Governor Ralph
Northam there are you know when we talk
about third trimester abortions these
are done with the consent of obviously
the mother with the consent of the
physicians more than one physician by
the way and it's done in cases where
there may be severe deformities there
may be a fetus that's non-viable so in
this particular example if a mother is
in labor I can tell you exactly what
would happen the infant would be
delivered the infant would be kept
comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mothers a discussion
would ensue between the physicians and
the mothers after the baby has been
delivered and is sitting on the table as
to whether or not they want to kill the
baby
he is explicitly talking about
infanticide which kirsten gillibrand is
denying and it's not just him in the
state of New York now you can kill a
baby under the reproductive health act
up until the moment it is being born
partial birth abortion throughout this
country you can have a partial birth
abortion where the baby is halfway born
and then you kill it
this is happening all over the place it
is being pushed by Democrats all the
Senate Democrats are for it
Kirsten Gillibrand is lying and she
knows that she has to lie because the
reality of it is too distressing as
sonograms become more widely available
and more advanced as the technology
advances people can see that the baby is
really a baby and it is freaking people
out and it is showing these radical
pro-abortion candidates for the
sociopaths that they are for the
sociopaths and cynics that they are like
Kirsten Gillibrand so she tries that
obviously people are just gonna go back
and look at North and look at Andy Cuomo
in New York
Andy Cuomo in his in his law the
reproductive health act now changing the
Penal Code so that if you kill a
pregnant mother it's no longer double
homicide it's a single murder that line
doesn't work so then they keep pressing
Kirsten Gillibrand and she finally has
to give finally along at last the honest
answer are you saying also then for late
term so I support roe v wade ok roe v
wade is the settled Supreme Court
precedent that decides the entire issue
and so I support roe v wade I believe it
should be codified it's been law of the
land for over 30 years I love this
answer from Kirsten Gillibrand because
it's so honest in its performance she is
like a criminal being interrogated by
the cops and she's given a whole bunch
of different stories they said what do
you think about late term abortion
Kirsten because what were you talking
about late term abortion this is a this
is a red herring debate this is the Fox
News I don't want to hear about Fox News
answer the question well I just a Fox
News talked about it for 35 hours ok
that's fine what do you think about
abortion well look I I think that the
infanticide it's not happening it's not
happening anywhere
answer the question Kirsten what do you
think about abortion okay okay
I support Roe versus Wade okay
that's her direct sentence I support Roe
versus Wade okay like a criminal
excusing herself like someone admitting
it like it's a confession she's
desperate she's tried now for several
minutes to
get around the square she goes okay you
caught me I support Roe versus Wade I
think that a woman should be able to
kill her child up until the moment of
birth maybe after birth I don't know at
least until the moment of birth she is
admitting that and it's that okay that
gives away the whole story because if
you asked me what do you think about
abortion I'd say I oppose abortion is it
you say okay I guess that would be the
end of the discussion if I were beating
around the bush I wouldn't need to say I
oppose abortion okay I'm not trying to
hide it because our opinion is correct
we should not kill babies that's the
right opinion that's the moral opinion
that's the right side of history if you
believe in sides of history feel totally
comfortable totally at peace with that
opinion she doesn't feel at peace with
her opinion Democrats don't feel at
peace about their opinion one because
it's immoral and two because its
electoral suicide the majority of
Americans want to change roe versus wade
the majority of Americans either want to
change Roe versus Wade or overturn it
completely this is an electoral loser
for Democrats and this brings us to our
favorite darling of the Democrat Party
the socialista from Northern Westchester
who pretends she's from the Bronx
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez who faced a lot
of electoral trouble now going back to
her district
she was walked out on by a number of
military veterans now this hasn't
happened too much before not because she
hasn't offended a lot of military
veterans but because she never goes back
to her district a lot of people are
saying she was elected in January and
that was the last time they saw her
until last month when she showed up cuz
she's got a campaign again but she just
went to DC you got to remember she's not
from her district either she's not from
New York's 14th she grew up a town over
from me in Northern Westchester she grew
up actually in a ritzy er town than I
did and she lived there and all
throughout high school then she all
throughout elementary middle school and
high school then she went to college in
Massachusetts then she came back and
according to Westchester land records
lived with her mother in Northern
Westchester until 2016 then she worked
in Manhattan as a bartender for a little
bit then she went to Congress now she
lives in DC so she's spent virtually no
time in her district she's going back
and it looks like they're not too
be with her so she was at a private
meeting with Bronx community leaders and
two military veterans stormed out
according to news reports because she
was knocking the country she was
insulting the country one of them said
quote she knocks the country she knocks
the president and that's not what
America is about that man's name is
Sylvia Manzella Vietnam War veteran and
treasurer of the Community Board 11
another guy Anthony Vitale Yano and Army
veteran who worked in the police
department for 38 years he also was the
head of Bronx as homicide detectives he
was sitting between AOC and a staffer
for AOC and he said quote I just
couldn't hear her BS anymore so I got up
got my umbrella in my hand and walked
right out say you know he's a true New
Yorker as he keeps the umbrella by him
all the time
it's a bad look here's my advice for
alexandria casio cortez it's a bad look
to attack the united states it's a bad
look to constantly be criticizing your
own country in this she was attacking
american military policy and foreign
policy bad looked to do that especially
when you finally show back up to your
district and you're talking to veterans
in your district for the first time
probably not a great idea to start
criticizing the United States and what
the American military does the overall
message for the left ear not just these
20/20 candidates but especially as we
get into Pride Month is what Bill Maher
said it was Bill Maher's advice to
Democrats to message discipline when the
now de facto leader of the Democrat
Party Alexandria Ocasio Cortes don't
take my word for it by the way that
she's the head of the party the chairman
of the DNC Tom Perez said that AOC is
the future of the Democrat Party when
she is bashing America to a bunch of
military veterans when Kirsten
Gillibrand is endorsing abortion up
until the point of birth when Seth
Moulton is saying that America is
hopelessly racist and saying that people
who lost elections really won elections
when the entire left politicians
corporate America even our religious
institutions are embracing pride the
queen of all sins
the worst possible sin imaginable you
No you've lost the narrative fine by me
I don't want the left to win anything
so I'm perfectly happy for them to go
out there and say hey we're not just
talking about sex we're talking about
pride let's celebrate Pride and for all
of their politicians to talk about how
awful America is have they all support
socialism when you get booed for saying
America shouldn't be a socialist country
we all support socialism we all support
late term abortion good go out there but
you have lost the narrative you are on a
narrative that is fundamentally at odds
with the United States with our national
and history with our people and with
reality that's where the left is right
now can you imagine how fun the rest of
2020 is going to be that's our show come
back tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael nose this is
the Michael Nolt show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua Alvaro and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 hey it's
Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin
show a wild debate is broken out between
right-wingers on whether or not we're
fighting for a free and open society or
just trying to crush our political
enemies see them driven before us and
hear the lamentations of their women
sounds like fun but there's only one
place you can get all the right answers
that's on the Andrew Clavin show